hello everyone and welcome to a truly
important game uh from the second day of
the saint louis blitz tournament is the
fifth day of in general of the
tournament because first there were
three days of rapid then two days of
blitz and um
it's uh really a wild game between
hikaru nakamura and alireza firuja
hikaru is very very close to breaking
the 2900 a livestanding superior uh
regarding blitz and if he beats alireza
here with the white pieces he might very
well do it he almost did it in the
previous round had he beat levon uh he
would have gone over 2900 but he almost
lost in the end it was a draw uh but uh
this game is a really wild one and it uh
features a very nice line uh that i'm
sure you guys will enjoy uh so let's
dive straight into it so hikaru has the
white pieces and when you face a strong
opponent and you really want to win you
go for the areti opening knight to f3 by
hikaru and alireza plays pawn to d5 we
have e3 knight to f6 and c4 now uh we
have pawn the e6 end now uh we have pawn
to b3 preparing to think it to the dark
square bishop we have c5 by alireza and
the bishop to b2
at knight to c6 we have c captures on
d5e captures and the bishop to b5 so
this is the latest theory under it this
is the absolute main line and of course
both of them know this they were of
course in the candidates tournament so
they
have um really a lot of preparations up
their sleeve with bishop to d6 and both
players castle so castles castles and
ponte d4 this is the absolute main
weapon for white here uh c captures and
d for knight captures and now bishop to
c7 this is the tricky move in the
position that makes room for the queen
to come to d6 and then you are going to
put a whole lot of pressure on that h2
pawn and you are waiting with the
development of your light square bishop
so if white puts this knight on f3 you
can pin the knight and then again
threaten uh characters and checkmate
which uh is very annoying so this is uh
what happened in the game knight to d2
by hikaru knight captures on d4 we have
bishop captures and now queen to d6
alireza gets very nice development in he
threatens checkmate here
and now pawn to g3 and this is something
that no one wants to play but if you go
knight to f3 then bishop g4 again very
annoying like we said threatening
captures in the queen captures on h2 so
you would have to play g3 at some point
so hikaru goes g3 right away uh we have
bishop to a5 now a very very fine move
uh controlling e1 also the bishop is now
coming to h3 as the g2 square was
weakened and uh this rook might run out
of square so here pawn to a3 hikaru
prepares b4 to chase away the
dark square bishop bishop to h3 rook to
e1 and now uh bishop captures and d2
again this has all been played before
and this is still known theory queen
captures on d2 and now all it is that
brings the knight to e4 with tempo the
queen is attacked and then the knight
will be shifted to g5 uh from where you
will have access to f3 to h3 the queen
might come to g6 to h6 and it could be
uh i get very unpleasant for hikaru's
king so here we have queen to e2 and now
we reach a moment uh where the position
is a known one and it was uh uh played
this year in the women's chess olympiad
between uh and natalia buksha
that
natalia was able to win but in that game
uh the queen the e6 was played here
already instead of queen to e6 goes rook
a to c8 and both are kind of equally uh
valued by the engine so i guess it's
more of a
more of a preference thing uh but
basically the idea is behind there is
rook to see it you want to put your
queen on g6 gain control over the c2
square and then put the rook on c two if
the rook lands on c2 of course uh that's
as good as over as the the knight also
attacks f2 so here and of course it is
now as of move 17 that we have a
completely new game which is really cool
as this is a blitz game so here bishop
back to d3 hikaru grabs hold of the c2
square
bishop back to f5 and now pawn to b4 we
have queen to g6 now putting pressure on
the bishop here so you might
see something like let's say knight
captures on g3 opening up a discovery on
the bishop so rook eat the d1 hikaru of
course spots this adds another defender
to the bishop and now knight the g5
offering a trade of bishops but also
eyeing those h3 and f3 squares and here
it's very very tricky and like i said
it's unknown territory and hikaru has to
be very precise and i'm going to show
you how you have to play this and then
i'm going to show you what hikaru played
bishop to c5 is the move you have to
play you go after the rook on f8 and now
it doesn't matter what black plays for
example if even if he moves the rook
you're just going to trade here captures
captures and play h4 kick away the
knight and that's it you're you're not
worried about knight f3 king will come
to g2 and if knight to e4 then you play
rocket to c1 and black will always have
this unpleasant pressure but
that's how you want to play this however
after he carves f4 move uh that that
simply will not do now the position is
completely winning for alireza and
alireza just blasts through the position
bishop captures on d3
queen counters and the three hikaru
offers a queen trade and now knight to
f3 check uh point being that um
if you go uh if you go to f2 king f2
then uh rook the c to check is very
annoying uh but that's probably why he
car went king to g2 and hikaru saw oh no
this is this is it now and now alireza
can win the game uh in one move uh but
uh uh he didn't but just in case you
guys don't know what i'm talking about
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the absolute strongest move
for alireza while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting the uh
instant resign royal fork and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is knight the e1 with check look at
this look at this beauty uh the king and
queen are are forked here and there's no
defense if you move the king we capture
the queen and if rook captures any one
then of course the queen is undefended
so it's a free queen and alireza does
not play this as when he was calculating
this he never uh took into consideration
that hikar would actually put the king
on g2 he in his mind he probably saw
king f2 and he already planned for rook
to see to check uh so it doesn't matter
he can't play king g2 alareza still
continues with rook to c2 check it's
still winning for him only it's not
instant resigns as now hikar will get
some material for uh for this so if you
go for king captures on f3 then you are
getting checkmated queen h5 check the
rook of course covers the entire second
rank so you're going to have to block
this and now queen h3 is checkmated
there's no escaping this
so uh of course that didn't happen after
rook the c to check hikaru had to part
with his queen queen captures now comes
queen captures unc to witchcraft king
captures on f3 now hikaru got a bit more
got a bit more material than he would
have in that line but now just uh rook
to c8 doubling up
on the c file of course uh saying that
if you go something like rook a to c1 i
would very happily trade here captures
captures and captures and alerts of
course knows that he will win this end
game so hikaru cannot go for this he
goes rook to e1 and now ro queen
captures on h2 we have rook a to c1 and
now rook to c2 all it is is all right we
can trade but i'm keeping my queen on
the second rank so rook captures we have
queen captures on c2 and now bishop
captures an a7 and now the only question
is can hikaru create some sort of a
fortress here he has a bishop and rook
against the queen and uh five points
each so maybe it can be done so here we
have f6 creating a bit of a breeding
room for uh for your king also preparing
to start bringing it into the game the
show back to d4 we have king to f7 now
comes rookie two attacking the queen
queen to e for check king to f2 and now
pawn to b5 uh very important to stop
those two pawns and the a3 pawn will be
a target for the rest of the game so
rook to d2 uh and now pawn to g5 of
course uh um
alvarez will now try to bust open this
position and go after the white king uh
because when you have a queen against
the king it's uh very important to open
up the position so you can
use um
the queen to deliver checks so f
captures on g5 uh we have f captures on
g5 and now king to g1 we have king to g6
bishop to c5 now and queen to f3 we have
king h2 and now queen to e4 we have
bishop to d4 and now a pawn to h5 vial
there is a uh we have rook to f2 hikaru
just waiting to see what happens h4 now
we have g captures and now queen
captures of course you don't want to
play g captures that would open up the
the black king um uh doesn't checks so
queen captures an h4 and now king the g2
we have queen to e for czech king to g1
hikaru very happy with his fortress he
says if you can you will have to push
harder than this so queen b1 check king
h2 queen to d3 with check and knocking
to g3 we have queen e4 and now king to
h2 king the h5 hikaru now starts
bringing his king into the game or
rather alireza starts to bring his king
into the game king g3 we have queen to g
for checking h2 and now queen to d1
already still without a way of
putting more pressure on the white king
rook to g2 and now king back to g6 uh we
have bishop to c5 and now queen the h5
with chuck king g1 and queen to d1 check
players are very low on time so they
have to repeat the position a few times
as you do get that one second increment
after you make a move or maybe it's two
seconds i think it's one it could be two
i don't think it's three but i'm pretty
sure it's one uh so king the h2 and now
queen to h5 check repeating once again
king g2 and now queen to f3 uh we have
bishop to d4 and now alireza goes after
the a3 pawn uh queen d1 check king to h2
and queen to d3 this is what he comes up
with
we have bishop to c5 as the pawn cannot
be defended and queen captures on a3
uh rook to d2 and only now will he push
even further on the king side uh so
queen b3 we have king to g3 and now
queen to c4 we have rook to d4 attacking
the queen queen to f1 and now rook back
to d2 we have queen to e1 with check and
now he car realizes that it is over you
have to play rook to f2 otherwise you're
going to lose the rook here so rook f2
and now king to h5 now the king is
coming
closer into the position and there's no
good way to play this you can't move the
rook
you have to move the king once you move
the king then you allow alireza's king
to go in the position and uh that's
pretty much it so king g2 was played
alireza brings the king deeper king to
g4 now you haven't pinned rook to a2 but
it is far too late queen g3 check king
h1 king the h3 andy was in this position
on move 63 yeah it's too bad i know one
more move would have done it uh that
hikaru nakamura resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
so unfortunately hikar will not be
breaking 2900 with this game but uh he
still might do it uh if he like wins all
of the games
that are left in the tournament but this
was this was a fine opportunity uh sorry
king h3 here you resign because um
you're just getting checkmated queen e1
will be checkmate and uh if you stop
this let's see before you uh try and uh
get back with the bishop it doesn't help
still queen to e1 check uh bishop to g1
and now a nice queen captures with check
you have to block with the rook this is
the only move and now queen captures
will be checkmate uh and of course other
ideas aren't
really useful if you move the rook back
then you simply allow queen to g to
checkmate so
of course completely winning for alireza
uh but it's it's it's incredible how how
quickly the situation unfolded right
after they went into a completely new
game all it is it shows this over the
bishop to e6 that was played over queen
e6 that was played in that game in the
olympia that we mentioned and basically
uh three moves after this hikaru played
f4 and that is that is all uh that's all
he
already needed to win uh but it's still
weird how the mind works like uh alireza
alireza probably saw king f2 and then he
already prepared queen rook to c2
because it's winning but you miss knight
to e1 such a spectacular fork uh
and uh uh you know uh if it wasn't if
the if the rook the city wasn't winning
of course alireza would found uh find
this but as it was uh there was no need
to waste more time in a blitz game to
look for for other things
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it now i don't think anyone will
be able to catch up to alireza he has a
five point lead ahead of everyone and he
still hasn't lost a single game so it
doesn't seem like um like it's it's
going to happen for for anyone else so
everyone else is now basically fighting
for for second place all it is that just
uh
it's a it is he is he's just playing
flawlessly uh so yeah once again hope
you guys enjoyed it uh i would like to
thank damon targaryen and gary sharma
and parson suzy charlie and kudos
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check to all my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the saint louis event until
it finishes uh so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day